auch vor corona wallis parias leben
nicht völlig sorgenfrei
die frischgebackene anwältin steckte
mitten in einer scheidung aber in new
jersey fand sie eine wohnung für sich
und ihrem sohn konnte miete und rechnung
bezahlen bis die pandemie kam und mit
ihr der finanzielle ruin
als ich meinen job verlor hatte ich
gerade die miete bezahlt und das war's
dann
es war der anfang vom ende ich musste
mich arbeitslos melden
das arbeitslosengeld kann dann erst nach
acht oder neun wochen in der
zwischenzeit kam kein gehalt rein
sie sei doch klug und gebildet sagt lisa
nie eine alleinerziehende mutter in der
mittelschicht nie habe sie geglaubt dass
ihr einmal das wasser bis zum hals steht
sie privatinsolvenz anmelden und ihrem
vierjährigen sohn erklären muss dass sie
zum ersten mal in ernsten
schwierigkeiten stecken
als sein vater und ich noch zusammen
waren haben wir uns vorgenommen ihm
niemals zu sagen dass er etwas nicht
bekommen kann weil das geld nicht da ist
das hier hat mir die augen geöffnet ich
kann das nicht länger sagen offiziell
den bankrott zu erklären das war
peinlich
ein anwalt zu kontaktieren ihm zu sagen
ich bin auch anwältin aber ich habe kein
geld die schulden aus der zeit zu
bezahlen als das leben noch in ordnung
war
etwa 22 millionen us amerikaner haben
will smi in der pandemie ihre arbeit
verloren und die häufig an den job
gekoppelte krankenversicherung gleich
mit die not lindern das hat präsident
beiden nun zur top-priorität erklärt ein
corona paket soll her viel größer viel
wirksamer als die beiden zuvor umfang
1,9 billionen dollar
die kosten von untätigkeit sind hoch und
es wird jeden tag schlimmer
wir haben keine zeit das aufzuschieben
am ende der krise könnten wir laut
berechnungen mit vier millionen jobs
weniger dastehen das könnte ein jahr
länger dauern zur normalität
zurückzukehren wenn wir jetzt nichts
unternehmen
ein politischer drahtseilakt beiden will
eine überparteiliche lösung den meisten
republikanern ist sein paket aber zu
teuer
kommende woche beginnt das
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen
ex-präsident trump im kongress das
könnte die fronten verhärten und eine
einigung um wochen verzögern
das letzte hilfspaket brachte lizenz pro
jahr eine einmalzahlung von 600 dollar
das arbeitslosengeld wurde aufgestockt
doch die angst vor einer zwangsräumung
blieb ließ handys kreditwürdigkeit st
den gang zur suppenküche konnte sie
nicht mehr vermeiden
es ist eine schöne idee zu wissen dass
die tafeln ein sicherheitsnetz für
manche menschen sind aber wenn du das
dann plötzlich selbst in anspruch nehmen
muss da bist du wirklich dann auch in
fairfax im speckgürtel der hauptstadt
washington haben sich in der krise die
gesichter in der warteschlange geändert
hier teilt die organisation food for
others etwa dreimal so viele
lebensmittel boxen aus wie vor der krise
auch an immer mehr bedürftige aus der
mittelschicht
wenn sie durch die tür kommen kannst du
schon erkennen wer vorher noch nie hilfe
in anspruch genommen hat sie sind dann
ein bisschen peinlich berührt und
schämen sich und sie sagen uns dann ganz
direkt wir haben nie lebensmittel
spenden gebraucht aber jetzt bin ich in
der situation und ich muss meine familie
ernähren
das neue corona hilfspaket soll den
hunger bekämpfen unter anderem mit
weiteren einmalzahlungen und einem
erhöhten arbeitslosengeld temporäre
maßnahmen um die krise kurzfristig
abzufedern
langfristig krisenfest würde amerika
aber nur durch strukturelle reformen im
wirtschafts- und sozialwesen durch eine
bekämpfung von ungleichheiten meinen
experten
im moment sind 40 prozent der
afroamerikanischen und
lateinamerikanischen bürger der gefahr
von homer ausgesetzt bei den weißen
familien sind es 20
so bezeichnet es also ist das meer weiße
und mehr familien aus der mittelschicht
auf lebensmittelspenden angewiesen sind
sind immer noch doppelt so viele
schwarze familien betroffen
zehn monate musste ließ any mit
existenzängsten kämpfen im neuen jahr
dann lichtblicke eine hilfsorganisation
übernimmt ihre miete den vergangenen
sechs monate und dann auch noch das
schön dieser kühlschrank ist voll und
ich kann ihn wieder auffüllen weil ich
habe jetzt einen job und zwar durch
großes glück
eine kanzlei bei der sich ließen die
wegen ihrer drohenden zwangsräumung
rechtlichen rat holte bot ihr im januar
spontan eine vollzeitstelle an
seit zwei wochen hilft die anwältin nun
selbst klienten die in der krise
fürchten aus ihrem zuhause geworfen zu
werden
es ist toll denn fühle ich mich wieder
produktiv 2 ich helfe meiner community
das ist das was ich immer wollte und
zwar mit etwas mit dem ich selbst zu
kämpfen hatte meine klienten können sich
darauf verlassen dass ich sie nicht
schlecht beraten denn ich musste da auch
durch ein großer schuldenberg lastet
noch immer auf ihren schultern
aber es ist ein neuanfang für die
alleinerziehende mutter die weiß dass
ihr unerwartetes happy end nicht die
regel sondern die große ausnahme ist
[Musik]